Hello everybody. My name is Markiplier
And welcome back to Slither.io
Now I should be playing with fans in this one
I shared out this party seed on Twitter
And hopefully when this is done doing the loading weird thing
I don't even know what that's about, but hopefully there's going to be less lag
But, either way...
WAITING!
Oh so patiently!
(Inaudible)
There we go. Now I'm actually in a game and hopefully I'm going to be in the game with everybody else.
No?
Is that not how this works?
Oh boy. I really, really, really hope that I'm in the same level as everyone else.
Because otherwise, I'm going to be playing by myself and everything is going to be lonely forever and ever.
And also, where is the God damned dots? Oh I'm going towards the outskirts, I need to go in.
We need to go deeper!
I mean this must be a relatively new server
The people on the Leavitorboard (leaderboard) seem to actually be kind of small. Kinda teensy tiny
But I have a funny feeling that a lot of people are probably trying to join
And if anything like Agar.io's what's going to happen here, they're not going to trust me when it comes to me being me.
They're going to fudge me over so good...
Not good! Not in a good way! Don't take that out of context.
No you don't. Oh! Who's going to die?
Oh, that guy apparently. That guy wasn't even trying to die
He was just trying to be peaceful off on his own.
But look at what happened! Missed me, dickbag
Somehow I'm number 17 on the server. Horray!
Playing with fans is fun.
Probably just everybody trying to kill me is what's happening
[Laughs]
Sorry. I'll let you go, you can go. You're not worth it. You're not worth entrapping
Oh the party's over here-Oh that poor guy, oh that poor guy. I guess we're getting into the party now
Things are starting to move up in the world
and it often doesn't mean a lot of good for me.
Got that one
Ok. Good good good.  What are you doing?
Get out of here! Everyone's trying for me!
Everyone's gunning for me!
Ohh, people want me bad!
People want to eat me up!
Ok I'm going towards the outskirts. I need to circle back and go back in because
I'm not gonna allow myself to be defeated
My- apparently
This is weird. My giant pink snake is gonna be-
going into the center!
And eating a lot of balls.
Oh how'd this guy die? Doesn't matter gimme gimme!
Oh, so good for me. I don't even know how this guy died!
He just died and there's no one to pick up the pieces
Kind of just makes me think that he just
gave up and then logged off and then everyone was just left to pick up the pieces.
Well, I'm number eight on the leaderboard, so that's pretty good
shows my incredible skill- how did I miss these things?
Whoa! Hey buddy, how are you doing
How are you doing buddy? Ohhkay
Alrighty then
I have a funny feeling that people are trying to entrap me here
It's probably true
It seems like people are gunning for me when in reality they shouldn't
because they're not gonna be good enough!
What're you gonna do? Yeah, you better back off.
Yeah, people are just like in a holding pattern, it's so weird!
[Chuckles]
God, there's so many people. There's soo many people!
Eugh!
Uah, so close on that guy!
Really?
Oh hello. Alright then.
Whelp, I got this guy eventually.
He's mine.
In some regard.
[Laughs]
I wonder how much, how long can we play this game of cat and mouse
There we go!
Cat and mouse over!
Time for me to nom.
[Monotonous] Yay. Yum. Yum.
Ah dammit, there's some down in there, I'ma get em.
Oh geez.
Ok
I'm number five!
Still entirely possible for me to royally f**k this up!
I'm number four!
Oh, if I get to number three I'll be even better!
Oh boy. Whup, that guy died.
gimme that
I don't know if that was intentional but I'll take it
Aww come on!
Oh I'm number three!
WOOO
WOO I've officially done it!
I've accomplished everything I can die happy now! I can-
If I die it's gonna be totally ok (sure)
I'll be not angry at all about it (uh-huh)
I'll be totally chill
and relaxed and totes cool.(totally)
Bruh
It's gonna be... cool.
Totally cool.
Whoa that's dangerous. That was dangerous of me to do
Whoa that was dangerous!
Woo that took my-
that took my snake on a journey there!
And it wasn't a good one!
Whoa! Ahh, f**k you!
Whoa, almost got you. Uhh... Ok.
Still number three!
Man, number two is far off from me. Wow.
That is like, that's more than double my score
How am I gonna catch up to that?
I don't even know what the glowing, moving ones do
if their actually more beneficial than any other
They may be, they may not be!
Oh boy.
I'm number two! Oh God!
Number one probably bit the dust, or number two bit the dust.
But I'm number two baby! WOOOO!
Woo I'm number two!
You wanna play?
Whoa, how'd that guy die?
Who cares? Whoa. Ah!
Ohhhohohohoho that was like...
that was like narrowly-avoided derailment.
Oohoohoo! That was too close! I hugged that guy a little too close.
See, the big guy, the guy in first place's strategy,
he's just encircling everybody.
He doesn't give a shit, he'll play-
he'll play the waiting game and goddamn, he is good at it.
I dunno if I'm ever gonna get to that point...
but I got what I got.
And what I got is my big pink snake.
And my big pink snake is gonna do a lot of damage
Heheh, Darkiplier. Darkiplier over there
Hey Darkiplier!
You wanna give me you?
Markimoo's here!
Did you know?
It's good for you!
I need to get back towards the center because I'm missing out on a lot of the action.
I'm still number two!
There was a guy in
second place above me for like one second
then I'm just assuming that-
There's 'Mark's magnum dong'
Ah, I dropped my Magnum condom from my magnum dong!
[Immature chuckling]
Sorry, I'm immature.
Almost got me there, wooo...
That was dangerous, good thing that guy didn't do anything about it.
got him.
goat him.
goat him
Go team! GO TEAM! GO TEAM!
Broke ten thousand!
[Goober laughter]
Oh God! OH GOD!
OH GOD!
OHH MY GOD!!
That was NOT cool!
You barely escaped buddy, you barely escaped.
Escaped the wrath of the Markimoo.
none can escape forever.
You can try, but I will always catch up eventually.
Markimoo comin' through!
The Mark train is a rollin'!
achuga le achuga le chuga le
achuga le achuga le- [laughs at own weirdness]
I've gotta whole bunch of people here
but I don't know if that's gonna do me any good.
People just give up and smack into my walls.
They smack into my Giant Pink Snake.
Oh boy. You want to be part of the party?
Oh, you just helped me release them, so...
Oh, hello Septiplier!
How you goin' there with your Magnum dooong?
oh gosh, this is stressful.
I wonder if I could gobble up Septiplier? That would be, that would be a thing.
HA HA! I got-
Oh God. OH God!
OH GOD NO!
OH! At least you died!
OHHHHH FUCK!!
Ok...god damn it!
DAMN IT, I was #2!
I'll never be able to beat that!
Man, I couldn't have gotten to number one. Number one was going to be impossible
But maan, goddammit! Oh well.
So thank you everybody so much
bdehaluuu
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
This has been Slither.io.
If you want to see more of this and Agar.io, check the link in the description below
and play this game for yourself. It's super duper fun!
Thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always, I will see you in the next video. BuhBye!!!
[Outro Music: Crazy La Paint by MiniMusicMan]
[Subscribe to see more of Mark's Magnum Dong]
[You know you want to.]
[Outro Music: Crazy La Paint by MiniMusicMan]